in this video we're going to get a
little bit of practice dividing by a
two-digit number so let's say that we
have 4781
divided by
32. pause this video and see if you can
figure out what that's going to be and
if there is a remainder figure out what
that remainder is going to be
all right now let's work on this
together so first let me rewrite 4781
and this is going to be divided by
32. now whenever we divide by anything
that has more than one digits it's a
little bit of an art the way we're going
to tackle it is a little trial and error
using estimation
so we'll start by saying hey how many
times does 32 go into 4 well 32 doesn't
go into 4 at all so then we'll move on
how many times does 32 go into 47
well it's pretty clear that 32 goes one
time into 47 so i'll put the 1 right
over there above the 7 in 47 and if
you're saying hey how did sal know that
well just remember 2 times 32 would be
64. that's more than 47. so 32 goes into
47 one time now we multiply 1 times 32 1
times 2 is 2 1 times 3 is 3 you knew
that 1 times 32 is 32 and then we
subtract 32 from 47. let's do that and
we get 7 minus 2 is 5 and 4 minus 3 is
1. and the way you make sure that you
did that step right is whatever we get
over here should be less than 32. if
whatever we have here is 32 or greater
that means we could have had a larger
number up here but then our next step is
we bring down
the 8
and we say how many times the 32 go into
158
now this is a little bit tricky if you
were estimating how many times does 30
go into 150 you might say 5 and actually
this is for kicks let's just try that
out let's see if 5 works
so let's see 5 times 2
is 10.
we'll put zero ones and then we will
have one ten there carry the one five
times three is fifteen plus one is
sixteen so that didn't work out it
almost worked out but not quite 160 is
larger than 158 so 5 is too much there
so
we need to go
down to 4.
so 4 times 2 is 8
4 times 3 is 12 and now we subtract
and 58 158 minus 128 eight minus eight
is zero
five tens minus two tens is three tens
and then we have no hundreds and then
this is right because thirty is less
than thirty two
and then we can bring down
we can bring down that one now how many
times does 32 go into 301
well we might be tempted to say well
this is close to 30 this is close to 300
so maybe it's 10
but 10 times 32 would be 320. so that'd
be too much so i feel good about 9
as my estimate
9 times 2 is 18 carry the 1. 9 times 3
is 27 plus 1 is 28
and then we can subtract and we're
actually going to do a little regrouping
here you might be able to do it in your
head to go from 288 to 301 let's say you
would add 12 to get to 300 and then one
more 13. so you might be able to do it
in your head that this is going to be 13
or you could regroup you could say all
right let's see one is less than eight
can i regroup from the tens place no i
have nothing there so i have to regroup
from the hundreds place
so i'm going to take one of those
hundreds i'm left with two hundreds left
and then i'm going to have ten tens and
then i can take one of those tens so i
have nine tens left and give it to the
ones place so now i have 11 ones and 11
minus eight is three nine tens minus
eight tens is 110 and then the hundreds
200 minus 200 is just a zero and so
there we have it this is less than 32 we
have nothing left to bring down and so
we're left with the remainder of 13. so
this is going to be equal to 149 with a
remainder
of 13. and we're done